foreign
thanks for joining us today for our
discussion about growing your app
monetization career at the groove Cloud
credentials I'm Alan ranciato I'm a
learning portfolio manager with Google
Cloud
hi I'm Masha khairi I'm a solution
manager at Google Cloud focused on
application modernization
today we're going to talk about some
things first our Google Cloud Learning
Journeys Ministry Trends the app
modernization learning path and some
other things that might be interesting
so at modernization what is it so here's
a quote from Gartner about atmod talks a
lot about the different things that are
included in app modernization things
like re-platforming re-hosting recoding
re-architecting re-engineering a whole
bunch of reads whole bunch of different
stuff in a lot of terms but what does
that mean here at Google
so we also Alan have a lot of reasons
because it's it's just Rhymes it kind of
Rhymes well with what complex issues
customers are trying to solve when they
modernize a lot of older applications
that need to come into a more modern
environment some of them can be retired
some of them need to join the modern
world some of them are refactored and so
um our goal is really to make this a
complex Journey easier for our customers
cool so you're saying there's not like
one size fits all for everybody there is
never one size fit all if you try
clothing that fits it never fits let's
just say that and so um let's talk about
some industry Trends how about that cool
yeah tell us about what we're seeing in
the market right now yeah because what
they're saying is the industry
ecloud but we're there are um
is the future they want to make sure
that the goodness of cloud is harvested
and the goodness of cloud is in Cloud
native Technologies think about managed
Services manage databases and um the
reason is if you look at how
um our industry is dealing with older
stuff the Legacy applications and I
don't want to call them legacies more
traditional but the truth is that these
older applications are taking a lot of
energy from their designers and their
developers and the maintainers to be
just alive and so what we are trying to
do is help our customers move these
applications into a more modern world
where managing these applications are
easier
and um to do that
my team is really focusing on creating a
program that helps customers with
understanding where they are because you
can't really make any change unless you
know what you need to change and then we
help them plan and execute a plan that
helps them move forward with different
aspects of modernization that they need
to think about so if you look at and
this is an eye chart it's a lot I don't
I'm not going to go through all of this
but the three things that I want to
point out are the categories that are
included in this after we assess and
help analyze where the customer is we
then focus on three main categories one
moving the older stuff into a more
modern environment and helping customers
take advantage of some of the available
Technologies like apis to join some of
these older
technology applications with other more
modern app ecosystem we then try to help
them operate and build their new
applications in the new environment
Cloud right because while you don't have
to patch servers anymore you still need
to configure and optimize your
environments and then the third category
is what I call cloud and Beyond the
Beyond is innovation right now that
you're in the cloud you have much more
Innovative power you can really
redirect that energy you're putting into
maintaining your older applications into
creating much better more proficient
more performant applications
does that make sense yeah yeah
absolutely super cool it's a lot it's a
lot but we rely on your team Alan to
help Engineers come along and become
more self-sufficient right so maybe you
cannot talk about what your team is
doing to help our Engineers definitely
so we talked a little bit about
customers and how your team is helping
customers what we're trying to do on my
team is really work with people because
the customers can't do it without their
employees without the people actually
knowing how to do it so what we've done
is we've created some learning paths
we've got learning paths for cloud
developers Cloud devops Engineers API
developers and Engineers hybrid Cloud
Engineers really understanding how to
learn these things and what we're doing
and how to support give people the
skills to be able to support these
initiatives that organizations are doing
so you know from a career perspective
it's really really helpful to have that
and to understand it and to learn it so
here's an example
um under your build and operate
pillar of camp
of a cloud devops engineered learning
path and really some of the things we've
got courses we've got Labs challenges
certifications things like terraform
things like logging monitoring
observability within Google Cloud all
the things that a devops engineer would
need to know to be able to be successful
in their role
um additionally we've got other learning
paths like the hybrid multi-cloud with
other skill badges other courses things
like Google Google kubernetes engine
architecting hybrid Cloud infrastructure
with anthos lots of different courses
lots of different skills to learn
and then with all of that we have
multiple ways you can learn So within
Google Cloud Learning and getting to
that we've got instructor-led training
so we can do on-site we can do virtual
training we've got an on-demand training
uh which is going into either a Google
Cloud skills boost or one of our partner
sites and watching courses and doing
Labs like that we've got Hands-On labs
and Hands-On labs are really cool
because you get to actually play with
Google Cloud so rather than using your
own money to spin up a bunch of
resources and leave them up and running
and you know the company now is coming
after you because they're like why are
we spending all of this on cloud you're
like well I'm just trying to learn I set
up a cluster and I forgot I left it
turned on on the Hands-On louder this
allow you to do that without actually
paying for the resource you're doing
we're doing it as part of the learning
platform but you get that hands-on
experience
and then once you get all of that we've
got credentials and certifications to
really help upskill
um the end user and how help employees
learn this stuff and then use that on
their resume to share it with their
networks and really be confident that
one they know what they're doing and two
their employees or their potential
employers
trust them to do what they're doing
that's really very your career
Improvement come in where you can
actually prove that you know this stuff
and these skill sets are really really
in demand absolutely
So within Google Cloud credentials we've
got several different types of
credentials we've got completion badges
so as you're going through our platform
as you're going through the courses you
get badges to say that you've completed
these
um then we've got skills matches skills
badges are really cool because skills
badges are basically a set of labs so it
might be four to six Labs where you're
learning as part of those laps so it's
Hands-On and you know as a former
developer
I don't really want to watch videos all
the time I want to play and so I want to
get there I want to build infrastructure
I want to write code I want to deploy
that code I want to see how it works so
the skills badges allow you to do the
Hands-On but then they test you at the
end and there's challenge labs
um to prove out that you can do what
you're doing
um and that you know what you're doing
and then you can take all of those and
you can share them up on your LinkedIn
profile and your profile within Google
Cloud skills boost and show your
employers to show potential employers
what you're doing and what you know and
then beyond that we've got
certifications and certifications right
now on Google Cloud are some of the
highest paid and highest sought after
certifications
so we've got things like Cloud architect
we've got things like um you know the
cloud developer we've got our
professional devops engineer
certification it's a specialist
certifications to really look at uh look
for in the industry right now
and then if you want to take these the
exams are you know their proctored exams
they're two hours in length that really
industry standard type stuff mobile
Choice multiple select
um we've now started offering them
virtually as well so you don't have to
go to a testing center to do this you
don't have any prerequisites but we
highly recommend three years of Industry
experience plus at least a year of
design and Management Solutions
because they're not easy no I've taken
some of these and yeah they're not that
easy but they're worth it they're worth
it they definitely are and yeah and I'm
really glad I'm helping build these Now
versus taking them because they're uh
I've taken a lot of them and they're
definitely a lot of study time
a lot of work
so um let's talk about other aspects of
modernization one of these aspects is
um not not necessarily technology but
people and culture and so what I wanted
to talk about was devops research and
assessment Dora this is not the door
Explorer it's the other Dora
um it's a scientific Dora and um
basically Ellen what this does is um it
was a research project that Google
acquired in 2018 because we really were
impressed with their mission and their
approach to understanding what is the
effect of good devops practices and um
since then we've continued to do the
research and every year we publish the
report but what we also have done is
this part of Camp
um door assessment is offered to our
customers as a starting point where they
want to understand how to become better
and um Dora
has created
um four levels where the industry um the
participants can basically are
categorized and is for um Elite to low
level in maturity or devops and then
with Dora assessments we help them
recognize and identify where they're
lacking and how to improve to become a
more mature devops company and um if you
look at the next slide you can see that
this actually works and this is backed
by data this data is collected from 30
000 people every year we send
questionnaires out and we collect their
input and be compile it and which you
can see is that there is a huge
difference in the performance in the
speed of deployment between people that
have adopted really good devops
practices and companies that haven't and
this goes beyond technology but
technology really helps because if you
don't have good tooling you cannot
create a blameless
postmortem kind of culture because
people will point to the tool actually
and be like this is not great so what
you want to do is move all of this
forward together and create a
psychological safe environment where
people have worked really well together
but also pay attention to tooling super
cool yeah and I mean it's a lot about
like how great I can Implement Jenkins
or Implement a cicd tool but if I'm not
actually performing and don't have the
people working correctly together and
talking and communicating in the right
way
um it's just not gonna work yeah tools
as I want but I I need to know what the
most efficient way to work as an
organization is is super helpful
absolutely and we bring in resources
um from Google from our partners to sit
with our customers and really study and
um dig in to these practices and um then
we have workshops like SRE principles
workshops where we come in and we show
customers how Google does it how we
recommend they do it and we also point
to tools like I said without the tools
you're not going to be able to be very
successful to go far and so we help
couple these toolings and education and
all of this come together to help our
customers really modernize the way they
go after software development
awesome so these apply to all Industries
so it doesn't matter what industry
you're in you need good devops practices
but I know that there are other
Industries more regulated industries
that have a specific need and maybe Alan
you can talk a little bit about what we
do for those Industries yeah definitely
so you know I've come from both
Healthcare and financial services before
I join Google and you know one of the
big problems with that modernization is
a lot of these industries are highly
regulated and just working you know
worried about it and they're concerned
that this isn't going to work for me or
you know my Auditors won't like it and
what am I going to do how am I actually
going to modernize so here at Google you
know we have a lot of solutions that are
specific to the industries that solve
those strong s things like our Cloud
Healthcare apis or open uh banking apis
or doc AI it actually works within those
constraints that those Industries have
to worry about it actually covers a lot
of those things we've got regulatory
reporting and really to to
you know focus on those Industries
specifically and we have learning as a
part of those so we we can bring that in
we can teach about the healthcare
Solutions or the financial services
Solutions and actually work with teams
to get everybody up to speed to
understand what it takes to be
successful in those Industries within
Google Cloud
that is super cool because a lot of
times these industries feel left out
from what's going on from Innovation
that that's coming these are great ways
to include them and help them move
forward
what about what about the um other thing
that usually happens is
um the decision makers also need to be
included in the trends of Technology
what are we doing for those decision
makers to help them make better
decisions
so we've got a new certification in
Industry certification called the cloud
digital leader and it's really cloud for
Business Leaders so what it does is it
helps technologists work with
non-technologists so if I'm a developer
and I'm not going to go into this too
much here we do have some sessions up
next on this specifically but you know
just so you know if you're working with
say project managers or
Executives that don't understand what
the benefits and really the the
different pieces of cloud and why we're
doing what we're doing and why we're
talking about what we're doing there's
learning for them as well so it helps
increase Cloud literacy it doesn't
require hands-on experience so for the
non-technologist to really understand
what you're doing as a developer as
somebody working in app modernization it
allows them to really focus on the
learning and do what you're doing and
understand why and really what the value
concept is of cloud and why are we doing
that's actually interesting I think a
lot of Engineers try to do it on their
own and so um yeah
so cool uh well we're running a little
short on time here so um just to close
out here we do have some things from a
Learning Journey
um here at nets we've got our Google
Cloud challenges uh so from the dev Zone
there's some challenges to earn special
digital Badges and
um really get in with the learning that
we're doing here we also have a 30-day
no-cost training trial so when I talked
about the courses in the labs earlier
during this presentation the Hands-On
Labs you can get 30 days unlimited use
of those labs and actually learn Google
Cloud there and then we also offer
annual subscriptions so where we talked
about you know not having to use your
own cloud resources uh for you know
whatever the cost is 2.99 a year it is
like unlimited usage of our learning
platform to really get your hands dirty
and to keep on playing and to really
take all of the courses so really highly
recommend this it's all available
skillsboost.google and there's a lot of
information out there
and that's about it for me
um thank you all for joining us today
more information at cloud.google.com
training and Michelle thanks for your
time today and this was a great talk
yeah and thank you for including me in
your talk and um please everyone
check out camp
we have a lot of material out there and
um Dora we love to have conversations
with you and your team about how this
can help you and please don't be a
stranger because let us know awesome
thanks everybody enjoy next
foreign